في مخيم للاجئين بارين من اهوال الحرب
موهبه تبصر النور من ظلمات خيمه وتحتل
مكان مميزا في بلاد المهجر
الفونسو ديفيد النفاثه البشريه
فر والده الى مخيم اللاجئين في غانا من
الحرب الاهليه في الوطن الام لايبيريا عام
1999 وهناك رزقا بطفلهما الفندق الذي صار
من امهر لاعبي كره القدم في مركزه هاجرت
الاسره الى كندا وهو في سن الخامسه ضمن
برنامج اعاده التوطين واستقر بها المقام
في مقاطعه اونتاريو المزدحمه جنوبي البلاد
بدا يلعب كره القدم ضد برنامج مخصصا
للاطفال محدودي الضغط وتنقل بين
الاكاديميات الرياضيه المختلفه في المدينه
متخذا منه هويته سبيلا لاثبات نفسه في بلد
المهجر
وقبل ان يتم عامه الرابعه عشر وقع اول عقد
احترافي في مسيرته لنادي فانكوفر وايت
كابس في الدوري الامريكي
عام 2017 حمل اخبارا ساره للشاب المهاجر
حين منحه البلد المضيف كندا المواطنه
وضمه الى صفوف المنتخب الوطني فكان اصغر
لاعب يمثل الفريق الوطني في التاريخ انتقل
الى نادي بايرن ميونخ الالماني سنه 2019
وحصل معه في العام نفسه على جائزه افضل
لاعب في الدوري ثم جائزه افضل لاعب في
كندا عام 2020 ابدع في مركز الظهير الايسر
بسرعه الخارقه وقدرته على الموازنه بين
المهمات الدفاعيه والهجوميه واختراق
دفاعات الخصم وارسال العرضيات الدقيقه
نجاحه وتفوقه واثباته لنفسه لم تنقذه من
نظرات الاستعلاء والاحتقار فواجه اهانات
عنصريه بسبب لون بشرته بعد ان نشرت صديقته
اللاعبه في منتخب السيدات الكندي صوره
لهما على حسابها في انستغرام لتنال الكثير
من التعليقات العنصريه عن الفارق بينهما
في اللون سانده زملائه اللاعبون من مختلف
الدول والدوريات وجائه الانصاف عام 2021
حين سفيرا للنوايا الحسنه لشؤون اللاجئين
ليكون اول لاعب كره قدم على الاطلاق يعهد
اليه بهذا المنصب الشرفي ويصبح الطفل
الصغير الذي عانى اللجوء في صغره ممثلا
دوليا لهم ومتحدثا بلسانهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]